hello everyone and welcome back to some
rapid action unleashes we took a little
break during the world rapid and Blitz
Championship but now we do have some
time before the Tata steel starts and uh
well let's just uh let's just play a
game and see what happens uh I've uh
yeah I've also paused a little bit so I
haven't been playing any rapid uh but
you know it's not like I was good to
begin with uh shouldn't be much of a
trouble uh for me to get back to it so
let's check it out we are currently at
2251 uh let's uh continue our Ascension
towards 2300 and maybe Beyond we'll see
we'll see how it goes and uh you know
how how 2024 treats me uh in in the
choosing of
moves uh all right let's see who our
opponent is for this one I can't even
remember if I was white or black in the
previous session uh but yeah whatever we
get uh we're not strong in openings but
we do love to to think sometimes even
too
much uh all right so not finding an
opponent for us let's try to remake this
all right 10 minutes per player 0
seconds increment um trying to always
play a stronger opponents that's why
maybe it's uh takes a bit longer to to
get an opponent but I'm sure pretty sure
it'll
be yeah any any moment
now maybe leeches is update oh no there
we go all right so let's get out of Zen
mode our opponent is uh Conrad the red
con R the red and we're going to open
with Pawn to E4 all right let's see we
have the Sicilian Defense and I just uh
uploaded the game yeah so A6 is is a
fine move uh but our opponent hasn't uh
put a knight on F6 so we still don't
have to worry about the defense over our
E4 pawn and I don't know uh anything of
this other than I've read once that A6
is best counter with Pawn to C4 and it's
the the the marozi setup we're going to
uh play D4 at some point but uh yeah
other than that should be should be very
strong for white positionally but later
on okay black can undermine those pawns
um so it's pretty pretty standard way of
playing against the Sicilian yeah Bishop
comes we're going to play Bishop to E3
and he will try to probably trade on D4
at some point um uh but first something
like D6 Bishop to D7 will be played
maybe then he trades puts the bishop on
C6 to put pressure on E4 and I will most
likely put the pawn on
F3 uh to to help me defend my Center
again all depending on what he does so
there yeah I mean there are many ways
you could play this but uh for for the
moment we're going
to uh we're going to play solid moves
all right so is there a way for me to
get something more out of the position
for the moment not really we're just
going to play Bishop D2 and uh prepare
the castle maybe some King H1 action
after castles then maybe some F4 action
or or maybe F3 again we'll see what it
does I'm trying to play faster moves not
uh okay let's just Castle
uh I know in a couple of the the
previous videos that I played I
overexplained uh you know certain
positions and then I run into time
trouble too quickly but yeah King H1 uh
fairly standard move especially if you
want to laune forward with F4 and I
still don't have to play something like
F3 maybe if he goes like Bishop D7 and
then he trades and then goes then okay
F3 will be a good move but by by the
time that happens I think we can even go
Queen okay so he goes um yeah it's very
interesting he wants to go after my dark
Square Bishop but
uh
yeah it's a it's a pretty standard way
of freeing up the D4 Square as he wants
me to capture here and then get my queen
over there and then capture on D4 I know
it usually works I don't know if it
works here in this particular line like
it either does or it
doesn't uh I mean if anything we can
take a
pawn if anything we can take a pawn
here
uh it's not
much okay he can win it back by giving
up the bishop so yeah I never even
considered him giving up the bishop but
he he probably will do
it yeah he will do
it okay so he will take back on e4 and
he he has a bit of a better Pawn
structure uh but I don't know I don't
know he's still completely undeveloped
so if he wastes one more move taking
that
pawn uh maybe we can maybe we can make
something out of it yeah he grabs here
we can grab on
D6 uh he grabs on E3 and then
well I don't know I've never seen it
that's why I just captured so
fast uh but if he doesn't capture on e4
I'm just going to play Queen to D4 and
good luck getting rid of my Queen from
D4 for for the rest of the game pretty
much yeah he's not going to take it okay
so we're going to play Queen
D4 uh Queen E5 not
really interesting for
me
um yeah we can
even play Rook F4
here yeah let's not let's not slow play
this yeah let's double up on the F5
our rook and queen nicely guard the pawn
and then we can if we really need to
we'll defend it with Bishop to
D3 yeah he goes after the
pawn
um yeah we're going to defend it for the
moment no reason not
to yeah I don't know if he has some some
G5 moves but I I really doubt that so if
he has anything it's Queen E5 but uh if
he plays that then we just fix our Pawn
structure it's not not the most
impressive Pawn structure but yeah if he
if he plays Queen E5 which is kind of
the only active
move uh I'm thinking we are we're we're
just better
here maybe I don't even have to trade
Queens uh I can play for some activity
but it's hard to imagine any activity
with the queen on E5 so probably he will
play that if he doesn't I can't even
figure out what what he could
play yeah but probably probably Queen E5
will just play Rook a to F1 put some
pressure on F7 make it hard for him to
figure out how to go about this and then
if Queens get traded off the board uh
we'll probably yeah he'll play
that
naturally
uh yeah we'll play Rook a to
F1 and uh if he trades yeah it's
fine probably capturing with the E Pawn
is the way to
go okay I'm not really
not really buying
that he's sort of saying that he has a
way of improving his position before
capturing on
D4 okay he he actually might be able to
do
this
h i play Queen B6 does he have Queen
captures on C3
yeah it probably
does probably does yeah so Rook e six
does seem maybe like an like a move that
he can play to make his position a
little bit
better
huh yeah and then he he's going to
trade and uh or if he trades I could
capture maybe with this Pawn but no yeah
he can't double up here so let's just
play H4 and see what's the what's the
idea behind Rook E6 not like he will
double up or
anything no he actually wants to play
this
on
okay very
interesting yeah he doesn't figure
out although I'm I'm still thinking
either holding the position doing
nothing or trading was the way to go but
we'll see he's the one who's willing to
invest more time in this okay so he
wants some back rank uh action
here um yeah which is perfectly
fine all right so now is the time to see
if we have uh any
moves like
H5 like Queen yeah okay so Queen D1
check will if we play H5 Queen D1 check
will just pick up that pawn so not the
not the
best we could sacrifice the A2
Pawn Yeah we could sacrifice the A2
pawn and then play
H5 just to make things
interesting as he can't really ignore
the pawn if okay so he ignores the pawn
okay very
interesting is he considering captures
on H5 that would
be I mean it could be
possible because then if Rook G4 he has
Rook
G6 yeah okay if if captures I don't have
Rook G4 but I can bring the other rook
in and also I have E5 which is just very
nasty now he will give a check first
okay we're not going to fall for
that what is
this what is
this
yeah I'm looking forward to seeing uh
all the all the moves that I've messed
up after we analyze the game afterwards
but I'm thinking
uh now once H6
lands yeah but even with H6 F6 seems
like a possible
move yeah it's not the
worst not the
worst yeah I'm not going to do that just
yet
um
but I still can't see how how he defends
against H6 like if F6 we can just trade
everything
there and does he have a move that gets
him back into the game I don't see it
yeah probably it's
some or or he just completely forgot
that I can push
H6
yeah I don't
know yeah it was uh it was maybe a bit
uh too much trying to play with uh two
sets of doubled pawns but he wanted more
than trading Queens on D4 and he got
into
trouble uh
maybe yeah so okay he gives up the D6
Pawn uh
which we have to take okay he does have
a
check but then we just
move and then he takes the
bishop and then Queen F6 okay he takes
the pawn it's not bad not bad at
all but what if we take yeah Rook E5 is
very
smart very smart indeed
okay Rook E5 wow what a
find we can play Bishop D1 very
annoying yeah Bishop
D1 yeah now The Rook is pretty much
stuck there he will play What's the only
move for black queen A3 he has to guard
the D6 Pawn
yeah this game really is going on longer
than I thought it
will uh yeah completely missed Rook e
five
there so what queen queen A3 and then we
play Rook
F6 and then he has Queen C5 yeah and the
game sort of comes back to
life
uh
yeah I don't think there's anything
better than this no that he plays F5
wow wow what was wrong with Queen
A3 yeah probably something that I'm
missing uh but yeah of course he wants
captures and and
mate uh but if we take
here yeah he will he will show me what
he had in mind okay he'll take with the
Rook uh that's
nice it's very
nice
oh but I found a very nice one I found a
one huh yeah there's this queen E6 check
if he goes King h8 I sacrifice the queen
for
mate so he has to block with Rook
F7 then
what hopefully he just moves the king
but I don't think he will yes he has a m
threat now yeah he spots the queen
sacrifice or maybe he
doesn't maybe he doesn't maybe he just
H how to win a move that's the
question yeah we just need to survive
Checkmate
here
um
yeah very very
scary all right looking looking we have
time so we don't have to rush
anything yeah there's no no check that
will improve my position so probably a
dull move like Bishop F3 has to be
played yeah not the not the not the best
and then he will figure out a way on how
to capture on F3 and then maybe some
check pick up C3 and grab hold of this
diagonal yeah if I could somehow grab
hold of the diagonal yeah so trading not
really what I'm looking
for
H yeah I have to play Bishop
F3 and then probably not even capture
with the Rook I have to capture with the
pawn probably something like
this now I have everything defended
while controlling the the dark Square
diagonal and I can't tell yeah okay he
might play yeah that's a weird thing to
do probably queen queen E2 was
better um so what's the what's the
cleanest way to win this kind like Rook
D1 how does he defend
here
he wants to bring the queen somewhere I
don't know where yeah but Queen D1
should be
enough yeah now Queen C8 check will be
will be very
strong was probably strong even without
Rook to D1 but
uh yeah it's not like uh I would have uh
I could capture some pawns here okay so
now he just runs into mate uh mate in
two which is okay but I don't think
there was a way out regardless of what
he played all right so let's see this
shish kebab over game 32 moves of
questionable
play uh there we go all right so A6 C4
this is a very okay so Knight C3 not the
move you should play here D4 RightWay is
best but we trans oppos into the normal
stuff fairly quickly Bishop E3 D6 uh I
played the bishop D2 Yeah okay or you
could go for the for the real marozi
setup uh I decided to go for maybe a bit
of a quicker way to develop he played
Knight G4 yeah and here I blundered by
playing Knight captures and C6 why
doesn't it
work can aha Knight C6 first okay yeah
yeah it's it actually is a is a full
piece
okay okay okay okay and then and the
bishop is trapped
okay yeah or if you go there then Knight
just escapes this way yeah
okay yeah that's the problem I I knew
that sometimes it works sometimes it
doesn't but uh he convinced me that it
actually works Knight captures on C6 and
uh yeah we just Trad it down into an
equal G end game uh not over an end game
an equal middle game that should not
exist
if I spotted the tactic
correctly yeah okay Bishop D3 He trades
queens and now yeah he just should
either trade or do nothing but he goes
for this active plan and now he goes you
know looking for adventure I sacrificed
the pawn for
H5 Rook
F1 yeah H6 just winning here uh rookie
five yeah so captures was best okay what
what was the idea here Rook H5 check
King G1 and now we were wondering about
Rook captures and H6 but no he actually
has
this ah okay so more tactic training
needed Rook captures Rook captures Queen
here would have been game uh but I
played Bishop to D1 sort of allowing him
back into the game with that Queen A3
move that I mentioned but he played F5
and now is just winning but
yeah CLE not the best uh Rook captures
yeah Rook one to F2 is the way to go
yeah I play Rook captures Bishop
captures and queen D6 check I thought
maybe he wouldn't spot the queen
sacrifice but he did and uh
yeah here he just uh messed up
completely with King to f8 so I'm
definitely
Rusty uh you know from from not playing
not that I was Rusty all the time uh but
okay we we we do get get a win uh it's I
don't think we made
any okay we didn't uh what did did he
have sort of a clean win at any point I
don't think so so we missed some
completely winning moves but we were
never in a position where we could lose
the game uh so at least that makes me
happy uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it uh a nice way on how
to uh on how to handle the A6 uh cilian
you know just go for C4 then probably
the marozi is better than what I played
but uh you know whatever works for you
try that uh so yeah as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you all for watching and I will see you
soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day